with the production and consumption of
synthetic drugs rising dramatically meps
have been taking steps to close the
legal loopholes that allow chemists
developing core components for illegal
drugs to stay one step ahead of the law
at a clinic on the outskirts of brussels
chief psychiatrist dr pierre skippens
knows the effects the drugs are having
complications
drug precursors are used in the
refinement of heroin and cocaine as well
as the manufacturer's synthetic drugs
but they're also used in legitimate
chemicals production europe has been
criticized for weak controls that have
allowed the precursors to fall into the
hands of drugs producers they're now
tightening controls over a key precursor
ascetic anhydride or a a but that say
meps is not nearly enough i think we
should much more focus on providing help
where it's actually needed that is on
the local level on the very very local
level where people live that are in need
of help and there we should provide
services etc so i don't see the need for
having more eu legislation that goes
on a re on a restrictive manner the
whole drugs item starts in the families
in the sporting clubs in the schools in
the churches if we don't talk with our
youngsters about the risks of drugs use
we never can stop the problem sentiments
echoed at the coal face of the health
services dealing with the aftermath of
drug abuse
until that comes young people will
continue to experiment with drugs often
they're so new on the market there's
been no time to measure the effects
apart of course from the monumental
damage they cause